[Musique]
49 3 c'est le passage en force
le 49 3 c'est voter un texte qui ne
seraient pas financées qui ne serait pas
complet et 49,3 c'est un déni de
démocratie c'est remettre en cause tout
simplement les droits du parlement la
droite à réformer les retraites en 1993
2003 et 2010 et n'a jamais utilisé sur
cette question ô combien importante le
49-3 très fort mais mauvaise donc on ne
passe pas anne urgence une réforme
mauvaise au contraire nous demandons
qu'elle soit retirée
le 49 3 c'est un coup de force qui n'est
pas la solution sur un sujet aussi
important aussi fondamental d'autant
plus que je le répète nous n'avons aucun
élément et aucune information sur le
financement de cet immense réforme qui
concerne tous les français la conférence
de financement c'est un truc improbable
il faut dire que amener un texte de
cette nature à l'assemblée sans qu'ils
soient terminés
c'est quand même incroyable plus
personne ne se préoccupe de finances
publiques c'est comme s'il y avait un
abandon des objectifs de finances
publiques les déficits la dette ou ça
passe au second plan
tout ce qui concerne la souveraineté
financière de notre pays passe au second
plan
on dépense sans compter en vertu de
l'application de l'article 49 alinéa 3
de la constitution
nous avons décidé de déposer une motion
de censure à l'encontre du gouvernement
au nom de l'ensemble des députés du
groupe l'est républicain et nous les
républicains nous nous sommes à la fois
consterné et furieux consterné par ce
que il y a là un spectacle qui est
vraiment qui déconsidère notre
institution que nous sommes chargés de
représenter de défendre et furieux parce
que notre projet à nous il est construit
et cohérent
nous n'avons pas fait le choix de
l'obstruction comme le font de façon
parfaitement assumé d'ailleurs ils le
disent les chroniques ou les où les
communistes
donc nous ne faisons pas d'obstruction
nous voulons débattre sur le feu nous
avons affiché clairement la couleur
c'est à dire que nous considérons qu'il
faut un âge de départ en l'occurrence 64
ou 65 ans parce que évidemment nous
considérons qu'il faut modifier ce
système des retraites
[Musique]